اختتم تحالف اوبك بلاستيج اجتماعات استمرت
ليومين بعد التوصل لاتفاق جديد تضمن مستوى
مستهدفا جديدا للانتاج عند اربعين مليون
و460 الف برميل يوميا بدايه من عشرين
اربعه وعشرين ما يعني تخفيض الانتاج في 20
24 بواقع مليون و400 الف برميل يوميا من
مستويات اكتوبر 2022
بعد ذلك خرجت السعوديه باعلان منفصل حيث
اعلنت عن تمديد الخفض الطوعي الذي اعلنته
سابقا بمقدار 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه 20 24 كما اعلنت عن تخفيض تطوعيا
اضافي لشهر واحد قبل للتمديد اعتبارا من
اول يوليو بمقدار مليون برميل يوميا ليصبح
انتاج السعوديه تسعه ملايين برميل يوميا
ويكون مجموع خفض المملكه التطوعي مليونا
ونصف المليون برميل يوميا هذا قرار يساعد
على يعني تعزيز فرص استقرار الاسواق
ومنعه من التدبب الحاد والتذبذب الحاد
ياخذ النحيتين نشف فقط الى الاسفل ولكن
ايضا الى الاعلى نعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات
هي الاجراءات التي يجب ان نتصرف اننا
ناخذها
كمنتجين مسؤولين عن
مره اخرى نريد ان نثبت العالم انه نحن
نعمل
كبنوك مركزيه فعليه ناضجه تملك الادوات
والوسائل اللي تعزز من انها تمارس هذه
الدور
بفاعليه وبمهنيه
وقادره على انها تحقق هذا الاستقرار
المطلوب ولحق عدد من الدول بقرار السعودي
تمديد التخفيضات الطوعيه منها الامارات
والعراق والسلطنه عمان وروسيا ليبقى
اجمالي التخفيضات الطوعيه حتى نهايه عشرين
اربعه وعشرين نحو مليون وسبعمائه الف
برميل يوميا تضاف الى تخفيضات رسميه سابقه
بمليوني برميل في اكتوبر الماضي عدد تخفيض
السعودي الاضافي في يوليو
ولمعالجه النقاشات حول خطوط الاساس
للانتاج اتفقت بلس على تقييم القدرات
الانتاجيه لكل الدول الاعضاء بنهايه يونيو
20 24 من ثلاث جهات مستقله ليؤخذ ذلك في
الاعتبار عند تحديد مستويات الانتاج في 20
25 محمد زهير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات